this is Stacy plasquette and that she's
going after the sources the sources for
these guys I mean it's just incredible
did Mr musk contact you Mr taibi again
the attribution for my story is sources
of Twitter Mr schellenberger did Mr musk
contact you uh actually no I was brought
in by my friend Barry Weiss and so this
story there's been a lot of
misinformation
Ms Weiss thank you Mr taibi have you had
conversations with Elon Musk I have okay
uh Mr taibi did Mr musk place any
conditions the gentle lady yield for a
second uh as long as my time is not used
are you trying to get journalists no I'm
not trying to get someone else I'm not I
am asked no and to praise him for his
work this isn't just a matter of what
data was given to these so-called
journalists before us now there are many
legitimate questions about where musk
got the financing to buy Twitter
my name is Matt taibi I've been a
reporter for 30 years and a staunch
advocate of the First Amendment much of
that time was spent at Rolling Stone
magazine ranking member Plaskett I'm not
a so-called journalist I've won the
national magazine award the I have stone
award for independent journalism and
I've written 10 books including four New
York Times New York Times bestsellers
um I'm now the editor of the online
magazine racket on the independent
platform sub stack
I mean there's so much here it's
incredible first off she doesn't know
that Barry Weiss is a woman so she
doesn't know who Barry Weiss is I mean
to be at a hearing about the Twitter
files I mean Barry was one of the people
that have released one of the original
ones she's well known in these circles
so put that aside then she calls them
so-called journalists as taibi pointed
out they are not so-called journalists
they are actual journalists uh and the
fact that she's going after sources
which is the biggest No-No in journalism
which is almost dead but not completely
Sarah like just clown show 101 like what
what else could we say yeah I know and
there's there's there really is so much
to unpack there because uh it shows us
several different things at once number
one these people in Congress are
completely incompetent they have no idea
what they're doing they don't even come
to a hearing with the having done the
research on what in the world they're
going to talk about I mean you you also
uh later in that hearing that I think it
was representative Sylvia Gonzalez who
was like well I have this here a sub
stack I don't know what what is a sub
stack I don't know what that is like
they don't even read any of this
beforehand they just come in with a
narrative to push because they believe
that they are the elites and we are not
and we are not allowed to know when they
are collaborating with a private company
to shut down speech here's one other
little throwaway clip here somehow the
phrase threesome got brought up at a
congressional hearing enjoy this friend
works for Twitter or what is what is her
um she's a journalist sir I didn't ask
you a question I'm now asking Mr
schellenberger a question yes ma'am
Barry Weiss is a journalist I'm sorry
sir she's a journalist she's a
journalist so you work in concert with
her
um yeah
do you know when she first
um was contacted by Mr musk I I don't
know you don't know so you're in this as
a threesome
um there was many more people involved
in that there wasn't many more people
involved with it
it was way better than a threesome guys
but the point again these people have no
idea who they're talking about the
issues that they're asking about if
you'd like more sane takes on our insane
World check out our direct message clips
playlist and if you want to watch more
full episodes of our live roundtables
watch our round tables playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell